profiter du beau temps avec les enfants
avant la rentrée scolaire et faire le
bilan deux derniers mois les côtés plus
et qui on était plus proche ou avec les
enfants on fait beaucoup de ses
activités ensemble avec la famille puis
les mauvais côtés je pensais plus avec
la technologie parce qu'il restait donc
et avec les tablettes avec ce printemps
étrange plusieurs familles ont
expérimenté presse inquiétudes
télétravail et fermetures d'écoles pour
certains des pertes d'emplois et des
deuils jarry par des tireurs les allées
oui à cause de l'épidémie
on a tous appris à traverser mais que ça
peut être facile que ça a été une série
de remises en question peuvent pas par
rapport à l'enfant mais par rapport à
soi même parce que je peux être à la
fois le parent le pédagogue le
professeur puis c'est beaucoup de roland
au dossier d'un seul coup la confinement
ça allait beaucoup aux défis notre
capacité d'adaptation
donc mon dit notre niveau de stress de
base remonter de quelques coches maman
est aussi psychologue
nadia gagnier a recueilli les questions
de dizaines de parents dans les derniers
mois
l'insécurité des enfants qui faisaient
en sorte qu'ils étaient beaucoup à la
recherche de réassurance de quoi la
recherche d'attention aussi même les
ados ont fait se suivent pas vraiment
partout dans la maison
un moment où certaines familles dans
certaines familles aussi les parents et
quant à de travail donc stressé de bien
accomplir leurs tâches au niveau de leur
emploi mais il ya eu aussi des effets
positifs sur la dynamique familiale
il y en a dont avec se sont aperçus que
c'était positif qui ont re découvert les
bienfaits de ralentir un peu le rythme a
passé plus de temps avec les enfants
avoir du temps pour mieux se comprendre
on passe pas beaucoup de temps avec les
enfants ont souvent on ne sait pas bien
se connaître ça mais bien parce que je
peux passer plus de temps avec mes
parents mais c'est un jeu alliant
en deuxième année le retour à l'école a
quelque chose de rassurant
l'école finalement sarah sa marque un
territoire inscrire de limite dans
l'organisation de la vie d'un enfant
puisque une fois qu'on perd ce cadre le
co perd ses limites là il ya une
certaine forme de désorganisation de
désorientation aussi un retour donc à la
normalité ou presse ici à nourrice
d'état tirage au canada montréal